on se sent comment à 18 ans dans une
tranchée avec un coquard ans est à
défendre sa communauté comme sa peur
c'était poppers est un menteur je oui à
18 et et semblait commun des mortels et
était pas capable de mourir tu préfères
départ de quoi sans application de ta
vie mais la vérité est arrivée dans
visage que tu peux tu es tu peux de mon
vélo là le matin du 11 juillet 1990 la
sûreté du québec décident de déloger les
marques d'une barricade située sur la
route 344 à cannes et s'attaquer à peine
majeure à l'époque christine ariwa getty
nick rice faisait partie de ces
militants qui ont pris les armes pour
défendre leur territoire
il est l'un des rares oies rieuses a
accepté de revenir sur ces événements
pourquoi tu t'es impliqué auprès la
société l'eia j'ai grandi avec 6 pin et
là c'est plus grand que moi c'est plus
important que moi puis je voulais vous
pouvoir un développement sur cette terre
là je cherchais aussi meyrin
quand j'étais plus jeune parce que je
suis un enfant des sauveteurs
l'enjeu de cette crise un projet
d'expansion d'un terrain de golf et la
construction d'une soixantaine
d'habitations sur des terres sacrées
pour les mots qu on y trouve une pinède
et un cimetière
[Musique]
tu étais où physiquement ici le matin du
11 juillet 1986 dans les pinèdes tous
d'en bas obama caché pour dire qu'on
était dans les positions qui ont été
prévus ont été le seul de france que
pour faire c'est de faire des trous
d'entre eux puis nous protéger parce que
quand lescure interrompre avec l'effet
domino
[Musique]
trois heures après l'assaut de la sûreté
du québec une fusillade éclate
[Applaudissements]
en l'espace d'une trentaine de secondes
plus de 90 balles sont tirées entre les
militants autochtones et les policiers
de la sq eu le caporal marcel lemay et
tués dans les échanges de coups de feu
comment ça réagit lorsque tu as appris
la mort ce n'est pas triste
le monsieur est situé aux causes de les
besoins des riches pour est stable et le
coup de golf en fin de journée puis
jetez pas de corée bok
j'étais pas d'accord avec dedans 7
points loge de tellement triste puis
jetés par les gens qui en 1995 dans son
rapport sur la mort du caporal mis le
corner guy gilbert blanc la sûreté du
québec
selon lui cette intervention sans égard
à sa date n'était même pas justifiée
mais l'envié aussi à la conclusion que
le premier coup de feu de la fusée a
d'elle-même provenaient des occupants
autochtone toi qui étais loll qu'est ce
que tu en penses
les rapports des coroners ils vont
toujours d'huile des choses compte nos
hôtes et votent jamais à notre côté
parce que comme si la broye gros bras
gauche
c'est là policiers les brédois cela
c'est la cour ça marche ensemble une
europe une autre main du haut de la côte
de canisses attaqué la pinède est
toujours aussi majestueux et trente ans
plus tard les enjeux soulevés par la
crise d'oka sont encore d'actualité
récemment la crise ferroviaire qui
opposait les chef héréditaire est
souhaitée nos projets de gazoducs en est
un bon exemple
et ce alors que le pays est engagé dans
un long et difficile processus de
réconciliation avec les peuples de tôle
tonnes
houston ding rock il ya eu huit semaines
aujourd'hui le serais tu prêt à défendre
ton territoire comme cela fait ya trente
ans je pense une autre façon je pense
d'avoir un conflit armé comme ça ça nous
donne rien à ce point là mais on doit le
faire asseoir pire venait d'être en unv
une à l'autre